the Capitol Rotunda is closing at this
hour after being open for more than 35
hours so the public could pay its
respects to our 41st president mr. Bush
is just the 12th president to lie in
state in the Capitol Rotunda this
morning the former president's casket
will travel about five miles in a
motorcade from the East front of the
Capitol to the Washington National
Cathedral at his state funeral mr. Bush
will be eulogized by his biographer Jon
Meacham who also did the eulogy at
Barbara Bush's funeral and his son the
43rd president that's George W Bush
bianna golodryga is already there
outside the National Cathedral beyond a
good morning good morning to you Gail it
is in fact a day of reflection mourning
and honoring one of our Dear Leader's a
thing that will bring this country
together as it has these past few days
guests will start lining up behind me
over the next couple of hours to honor
the former president and those who were
able to make it to the Capitol were
given one of these cards to take home in
honor of President George HW Bush on the
back of it lists in chronological order
the president's more than fifty years in
public service along with a message of
gratitude from the family that
dedication to the nation will be honored
here today at the National Cathedral
where attendees will include President
and mrs. Trump and all living former
presidents crowds lined up outside the
Capitol in the cold and well after dark
Tuesday waiting to say goodbye to
President George HW Bush in the evening
members of the Bush family including
former President George W Bush stopped
by to thank the crowd and on an
otherwise somber and emotional day the
43rd president tried to lighten the mood
a fitting tribute to a man who loved to
laugh as his grandchildren Pierce Bush
and Lauren Bush Lauren told Norah
O'Donnell what's the best advice your
grandfather ever gave you it's more
themes from just how he lived but it's
always give the other guy credit you
know if you if you fall get up and I
think don't take yourself too seriously
that approach one mr. Bush respect from
all Americans at
capital we're members of the five
military branches stand guard and
changed the guard every 30 minutes
the president's service dog sports
celebrities like peyton manning in coach
k paid respects alongside disabled
americans whose lives were changed by
the Americans with Disabilities Act
the late Senator John McCain's wife
Cindy political leaders from both sides
of the aisle as well as close friend and
former Senator Bob Dole also visited to
pay their respects and in the afternoon
president and mrs. Trump stopped to
visit the Bush family a public showing
of peace between the families who have
clashed my dad was a really unique
special guy Jeb Bush said Americans
today could learn a lesson from his
father be bad to be the end of an era
where you're where you actually care
about family and you support one another
and you you show integrity and
compassion and courage we could all
learn a little something from the former
president now the funeral service here
at the National Cathedral will be led by
the Reverend dr. Russel Levinson jr. who
was with the president in his final
moments he was also with his wife
Barbara Bush in her final moments back
in April well afterwards the president
will be flown back to Houston and of
course will be here all morning to keep
you updated on the events throughout
this ceremony
and Nora when I spoke with Reverend
Levinson in Houston I asked him about
the president and his relationship with
his faith he said he was a man of simple
faith that he didn't want much fuss
going into his funeral services in fact
he said that it was Barbara who was
everyone's spiritual leader and of
course from all the stories you've heard
you can concur as well yeah bianna thank
you so much